allez à quelques secondes de l'article 7
nous sommes avec Gabriel Attal ministre
de l'action et des comptes publics merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous d'abord un mot
sur la tonalité des débats au Sénat vous
venez de remercier les sénateurs est-ce
que vous avez trouvé ça différent de
l'Assemblée oui on a eu de vrais débats
de fond projet contre projet avec
notamment les bons de la gauche qui
proposaient des augmentations d'impôts
de cotisation là où effectivement nous
proposons d'équilibrer notre système en
passant par un recul de l'âge légal de
départ ça s'est fait toujours dans un
cadre respectueux républicain c'est ce
que j'ai voulu saluer pas vraiment
d'obstruction alors pour vous de la part
de la gauche il y a eu quelques
longueurs mais on a vu qu'à certains
moments aussi ça accélérait encore une
fois l'important c'est qu'on puisse
parler de tous les sujets alors est-ce
que vous souhaitez quand même du coup
vraiment accélérer sur les débats pour
la suite on le sait il y a des outils à
la main du gouvernement à la main de la
majorité sénatoriale
les différents sujets il y a beaucoup de
sujets qui arrivent évidemment le recul
de l'âge légal de départ à 64 ans mais
il y a aussi des articles sur
l'extension de la retraite progressive à
la fonction publique sur la question des
carrières longues il faut qu'on puisse
examiner tous ces sujets j'ai pas de
doute qu'on parviendra à le faire alors
est-ce que l'équilibre financier de la
réforme va être assuré Gabriel Attal on
a Olivier du soft qui a dit dans une
interview que 300 millions d'euros
pourraient manquer en 2030 et puis on
voit un peu la note qui s'alourdit le
coup du CDI senior qui a été adopté au
Sénat le coup de la surcote pour les
mères de famille ayant toutes leurs
années à 63 ans la note va s'alourdir ah
mais l'équilibre de notre système de
retraite à horizon 2030 c'est un
objectif dont nous ne dérangerons pas
mais parce qu'il y a quoi derrière
l'équilibre il y a tout simplement le
fait d'être capable de continuer à payer
les pensions de nos retraités il y avait
12 millions de retraités dont il fallait
payer la pension au début des années
2000 on sera à 20 millions dans quelques
années c'est un doublement sur une
génération et donc la réalité c'est que
vous êtes obligé dans ces conditions de
prendre des mesures pour équilibrer le
système sinon ça veut dire qu'on devrait
baisser les pensions et on le refuse
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire que j'étais
défavorable au CDI seniors en tout cas
dans la manière dont il était dont il a
été adopté par les sénateurs puisque ça
coûte très cher et je doute de
l'efficacité mais c'est des discussions
qui se poursuivront dans la navette
parlementaire et en commission mixte
paritaire certainement est-ce que vous
reconnaissez quand même des erreurs de
communication dans la façon dont le
gouvernement a géré cette réforme bien
sûr on pense tous au slogan sur les 1200
euros depuis on a compris que c'était
beaucoup plus compliqué que cela et
notamment Isabelle borne a été beaucoup
plus clair et plus complexe ces derniers
jours d'abord une réforme des retraites
c'est toujours difficile moi j'ai pas
d'exemple de réforme des retraites
demandant un effort aux Français qui
était particulièrement populaire quand
vous regardez en arrière c'est toujours
difficile c'est une réforme qui est
assez technique et on peut toujours
considérer qu'on aurait pu faire mieux
mais je pense que l'essentiel c'est en
permanence de chercher à expliquer à
être au contact moi je les fais mais en
termes de communication on peut toujours
évidemment moi je cherche toujours à
être au contact des français via les
médias évidemment mais aussi dans des
réunions publiques que j'ai multiplié
partout en France partout sur le
territoire pour aller au contact des
Français et chercher à expliquer nos
intentions est-ce que vous considérez
que la droite sénatoriale comme votre
allié sur ce texte et au-delà des
oreilles mais vous savez en fait moi
j'ai jamais demandé à la droite
sénatoriale ou LR de l'assemblée de se
rallier à nos convictions tout
simplement d'être mais tout simplement
d'être fidèle au leur en votant pour ce
texte ils sont fidèles à leurs
conditions et à ce qu'ils ont toujours
porté en tout cas depuis des années ici
au Sénat merci merci beaucoup Gabriel
d'avoir répondu à mes questions on va
[Musique]